Tak.
Hello Shipton members. We will begin Part 1 of the
Chesley Morning Brief on Wednesday, June
24th, sharing happy investment moments.
Yes, first, let's take a look at yesterday's Chinese market opening with Director Wang Jing
. Yes,
Asian stock markets dropped a bit yesterday
.  So the index also
dropped by about 1.4%.  The Heungseungtae
index fell to minus 3.3%, while the
regular admissions overachievers maintained a level of 3.5 trillion
.  If we break it down by sector, yesterday
we learned that the finance, healthcare, and utility sectors were strong, while the materials and IT
sectors were weak.
Financial stocks are
showing some rebound, driven by the funds that were buying at low prices out of fear.  Agriculture rose 2.7%,
industry 2.5%, and savings
2.9%.
Due to the recovery of regular trading volume and the registration of substitute FPOs, the
government-owned stock price has also risen.  Jongsin Gangtu rose by
5%, and Geonbal Gwan rose by 2.7%
.  Stocks related to
light trading simply showed strength due to expectations of rising light trading prices
.  Yesterday, we were talking about the War Cannon
Ray.  It just hit the
upper limit of about 10% without any exceptions
.  Uh, Stagnation Tech
went up 3.5%.  With expectations for Bandose's capital increase and
other factors, Bandose's maintenance stocks
also showed an upward trend.  Bubang
Hwacheon has 3% inflammation, and Seungmisangha has
3% urinary symptoms. It is Jangcheon Tech. This company is a
company specializing in podiatric equipment.  Yesterday it went up 4%,
and the art style test went up nearly 4% again
. Many of these recollections and histories have been
reported.
Government-owned equipment was also strong, likely due to large-scale reconnaissance by PCB manufacturers.  Contrast
Laser recorded a 10% upper limit
.  The contrasting stock rose 6%,
and the ghost stock rebounded again yesterday
.  Oh, the inflammation in the Hwanneung Sujeon went up to
1%, and the inflammation in the Hwanneung Gubyeon went up to 8%
.  Meanwhile,
related stocks are maintaining their strength due to the announcement of cooking gifts
.  The Chinese one opened yesterday
.
China recorded a new high of 9% yesterday
.  Oh, on the other hand, materials,
PCBs, optical communications, and government-owned stocks all
dropped yesterday.  The concrete interest rate of the belief product yesterday
caused inflammation.  The specific interest rate for ideological products is
set at a certain P, and the foreign exchange
rate is 24%.
Yesterday, the Korean market [clears throat] performed the
best among Asian markets, although it is said to be due to leverage and ETF influences.
Even Japan fell by about 3%, and
assuming there is sectoral correlation in the Asian market, I
think China should have taken a sharp downturn, even considering semiconductor equipment stocks.
There were specific factors like that.  There is nothing particularly special about it
.  The reason prices have been
rising recently is that they
dropped a bit due to listings for the Sha exam.  If
you look at it from an IT market perspective, IT currently has only
7% and 8.7% undecided.   If
you look at the IT and CS 300 sector-specific indices here, the
CSI is
correct.  IT transportation fees are not at the 8-7% bar
.  So, even if you push hard on this part,
there is a possibility that it will have almost no effect on the retirement process.
When looking at global investment strategy materials centered on the US,
one of the reasons companies place the Shanghai Composite Index out of the Asian market is that,
because China has its own choices, indices
like the Shanghai Composite (CSI 300), which are composed mainly of competitive companies and top-tier firms by market capitalization, are considered
quite promising—a
natural, perhaps
obvious reason—and their
correlation coefficient with major global markets is close to zero.
So, there has been talk that if major global markets were to deteriorate,
investments made in the Chinese market would
act as a buffer to some extent, and I wondered if
those aspects were
somewhat demonstrated yesterday
.   yes
.  yes.  you're right.  yes.
There is also one government-run Hosan that I am bringing today.
Hmm. You just introduced this improvement once again at the beginning of this month
.  It's a street
situation, isn't it?
Hoesan [snorted] The current market capitalization
is about 47 trillion won.  Well, back at the
beginning of this month, the snow
fell again.  Currently, Ford's P is sevenfold, and
Ford's PBR is ranked first at around 300
.  Well, we are maintaining the number one position in the Chinese air conditioner market, with
domestic sales accounting for
74% and exports for about 12%.
Well, the first actual match comes out to me.
Consent rate increased by 3.5% to 5%.  Revenue
increased by 3%.  GP Maji
just maintained the fly level and
told MP Majipo to do it.  There are no particular problems
.  Well, based on the first period, the
air conditioner stock increased by 1.5% before trading and
is maintaining its number one position in the market. Um, the
company just released one public announcement at the end
.  The company received a plan to
hold shares with the executives and employees at approximately 5.3%
.
Watchholding
plan,
yes.  I am an ESOP.   that's
right.
Well, there are a few things regarding the win and the loss
.  If you look at the key points,
originally, they stated that next year, 100% would be based on a cash dividend of 18% or more plus a
50% increase, while the
lower end would be based on a dividend of 12% to
18% plus a total of
80%.  If this is
achieved, the
stock is given to the employee or executive.  But what is being given is
not living there during the tenure; it is just the company's operational power, a post-mortem assignment
.  This one was done
on an incentive basis.  At
the beginning of this month, I cooked rice after mixing and steaming the Hoesan liquor
.  They presented a dividend payout ratio of nearly
57.8% and 8%, and proposed that
over 70% of the shares be burned
.  As of June 17, the
company's expected PBR originally
dropped to 1.4 times, reaching a negative level.
From 2022 to 2024, it went
down to almost 1 win and 400 times.  The reason is that
there is concern about malnutrition at that time.  Because
of the rise in atomic prices,
there is some evidence in practice as well.  Recently, the parting
wasn't a mistake, but because the semiconductor industry situation was so
severe, it
became a topic of conversation like this.  So the
stock price kept going down.
Other than that, it originally exceeded this company's expected ownership rate by
about 10%.  1 Lightning
Market So-seung has about 17.73 million
.  So, if we consider the easing and transfer, it amounts to about
40 trillion won.  Well,
stagnation accounts for about 85% of the market price, and
excluding net pensions, the current blood price of Holsa is
just about 1.  yes.  Because there are only
7 trillion.  Yes, excluding cash.  After
withdrawing cash, looking at these Kwon Dae-Jung-Kwan repurchasers, I
maintained a buy recommendation due to the low price, undervaluation, and dividends.
Following the reduction of the government household purchase subsidy system, the original
29 billion, 30 billion, and 32 billion won each for next year
were launched, and just 4% of the designated amount
was targeted for parcel usage.  Originally, Takero was a ten-fold
figure, so he maintained around 54th place in TP
.  It could come out down 45% from yesterday's closing price
. Hmm, thank you
.  yes.  Let me ask you one more thing
.  At the very top of the street home appliance line, with a
market capitalization of 47 trillion won, is
this the Korean One?  I
converted everything.
Converted, the
annual capital is 177.3 billion
yuan, so if we
convert that to Korean won, it goes
over 30 trillion—not quite 40 trillion. So, if we
calculate it that way and
subtract all the annual capital, the
market capitalization relative to the actual profit is only about
1x P. It seems you are
saying it is incredibly cheap. You are right.
I view this as an investment opportunity that the market is not yet recognizing. Is there a
reason why the
stock price isn't rising despite the market capitalization being as high as 47 trillion won? Manager Wang,
where do you see more potential
?  Personally, I do
n't think there is any need to worry about performance, and you know,
there is also that volatility exemption these days.   Since
all these funds are flowing into semiconductor manufacturing, I
think there is a possibility that companies like this might rebound if the situation stabilizes.  Because this
company's stock price continues to strengthen during the week
. From a value investor's perspective, it is a
very high-quality stock.  You
can consider it a very solid line.
So, this
is a company that is somewhat marginalized.  yes.  That kind of feeling.   yes
.  I
had the thought that the company is generating operating cash flow equal to or even greater than its market capitalization—or rather, cash equivalent. So, you're
right.   Yes,
a promise to return those things fully to the shareholders is not temporary, but just continuous
.   If
there is a guarantee or belief that it is a considerably long period, then
yes.  Once the stock price has leveled up to a certain point, it may
fluctuate again depending on market conditions
.  I've been thinking about that a bit
.  yes.
Uh, when Manager Wang recommends Chinese stocks, there are
n't usually that many with a value-oriented style like this,
yes.
Uh, there are a few.
Ah, yes.
There is a company like this in China as well.  If
we find the right companies like this,
I think another style could emerge.  If you look at having only these kinds of
companies packed up like this, well
.  I think this is the kind of stock that could attract sudden attention when growth stocks or AI-
related themes suddenly
move in the opposite direction, so I will add it to my
watchlist as a good stock to
watch.   yes
.
thank you  That is as far as
we look at the Chinese market.  We should probably move on to the US market
.  Uh, regarding the US market, I just
looked at the headlines.  Yuripro
just... uh, Korea was like a gift to the US market
.  I do have a bit of that feeling.   Let's
hear the details from our Repro.   yes
.  Uh, as you mentioned, it was a bit... uh...
a gift, but the real gift... no,
yesterday was a day that ended really roughly
.  Now, if you look at the major indices first, the
Philippine Index, Nasdaq, SMP
500, Russell 2,000, and the Dow have
all declined.  The drop was the
biggest, starting with the general index.  Last
night, I did some trading around 11:30 and
kept tracking until I
confirmed the Dow was rising slightly before going to sleep. However, I woke up just
before the market closed today and
dug in for a bit.  It seems the
section that briefly rose around 4:30 spiked once more
.  Based on all standards.   yes
.  Based on the market, it did eventually
close with a decline, but due to selling pressure at the very end, it
ended with a slight downward trend.  So, I
viewed the Dow positively because it
went into positive territory twice during the session. I
mentioned this because I thought there might be some hints regarding the market rather than simply summarizing today's market as being bleak; however,
major indices fell sharply, and the
word "bubble" kept appearing in the chatter
.  However,
considering that the DAO turned positive twice during the session, it seems reasonable to view this as a market where there was some
defense rather than a complete sell-off, though there was a lack of certainty until the very end
.  So, while it still feels a bit unsettling that the Mouth fell towards the end, the
weakness in NAS and Philippine was emphasized to make it look like an overall market downturn.
Therefore,
rather than focusing on the Dacom method, I would say it was a market with a
stronger character of profit-taking to alleviate the concentration caused by the excessive rise in AI and semiconductors
.
So, if you look at the sector on the right as well, it was
n't a market that had completely declined.  The defensive sector
rose a bit.  As I
briefly mentioned in the comments at the bottom, the
healthcare, finance, consumer staples,
energy, real estate, and utilities sectors have
risen. Among these,
consumer staples, health, gear, and real
estate have increased by more than 1%.   On
the other hand, conversely, the information technology (
IT) sector fell by about 3%,
dragging down the overall index.   As you
mentioned, I
cannot help but mention the KOSPI. If you
move to the bottom left and look at the semiconductor sector,
you will see that everything was weak.  In particular,
Micron and SanDisk, which are
memory stocks dealing with DRAM, HBM, and Land respectively, have
fallen by double digits.
In fact, rather than the initial trigger emerging from the US market, it seems that the
downward trend spread to
US memory and semiconductor equipment stocks as the KOSPI fell by about 9.9% yesterday and Samsung Electronics and Nix, which account for more than 50% of the market capitalization, plummeted
.  As additional
reports continue to emerge regarding the
start of the bull market, Bloomberg
Tech conducted a few interviews yesterday, and an
analyst named Neil Campling commented on the weakness in SK Hynix and the Nasdaq
.
So, the
core of this analyst's comment was skepticism regarding the quality of the memory market.
However, some unofficial reports and market
comments suggest that SK Hynix is
adjusting the pace of mass production expansion for HPM and shifting its capacity toward DRAM, where prices are expected to rise significantly recently
.  So, while some verification is
needed, the mere fact that such talk
has emerged suggests that
discussions regarding production and profitability are taking place in the regulatory DRAM sector. Just based on this border
alone, the market is questioning
whether HPM prices, HI,
or AI memory momentum are
not as strong as expected. Alternatively, the
reports are
using expressions like "observing profitability by AI" to describe the situation.  So,
questions were raised regarding the profitability of such HBM. However,
according to official reports, we
must base our decisions on data. In the
case of SK Hynix, they have recently been supplying the
fourth-largest sample of next-generation HBM to major
clients and continuing to respond to AI memory. Therefore, it
seems more appropriate to view these comments of concern not as confirmation of actual demand, but rather as a reaction from the market questioning the possibility of changes in the production mix and profitability.  Also, additionally, this
analyst has been looking at the tech set for a long time
.  After doing some research, I found that he has
consistently made skeptical remarks regarding tech natives, so you should also take that into
consideration
.   I got my personal
information leaked by F.  [Laughs]
Yes.
Yes. Next, I
think we need to check oil prices as well.
If you look at the section below where I always attach the Krod Oil WTI, I have brought the WTI intraday chart, and it
continues to be in a downtrend.  Also,
regarding the brand, we were always attaching it as text, but we have
now taken both down
.  And it is also a continuing downward
trend.
I am referring to it collectively as "oil prices," and I am
talking about it primarily in terms of WTI
.  You might be wondering what exactly the difference is, so let me
clarify it once again. From a market indicator
perspective,
since WTI is produced on the U.S. mainland, it acts as a key indicator that
determines oil prices in the U.S. domestic market.
Therefore, it serves as an important reference point
when looking at energy and gasoline prices within the U.S.
Of course, a drop in WTI does
not necessarily mean that gasoline prices will fall along with it. However,
because gasoline consumption is high within the U.S., if inflationary pressure eases, we
can connect this to scenarios where the Fed raises interest rates less, or there might even be room for further reductions later on due to gasoline or WTI.
Since I have been continuously emphasizing that falling oil prices are linked to inflation and interest rates, I believe the fact that Brand Oil
and WTA have fallen together can be viewed as an indication that
inflationary pressure is trending downward
.  So, regarding oil prices,
[clears throat] I have already
touched upon inflation and interest rates once again. Additionally, another
point we need to look at in yesterday's market is
the news of
progress in negotiations with the U.S., which could actually be considered an
additional factor driving down oil prices
.  While it will certainly have a complex impact on the stock market, it is
at least a factor that could act as downward pressure.
Looking at how things are progressing, the
negotiations have advanced to the stage where a roadmap has been agreed upon to pursue a final agreement
within 60 days following a temporary ceasefire, rather than simply resuming dialogue. Although the
final peace treaty has not yet been signed, you
can view the 60-day negotiation framework as remaining open. If we
look at the key points of the roadmap released so far, there
are roughly four main paths.  The first point is the
establishment of cooperative governance, where issues such as nuclear matters,
sanctions, and dispute resolution will be
discussed on a practical level. The
second point is the
establishment of a contact line for the management of the Strait of Hormuz.  Third, we
will also establish a coordination channel to prevent military-industrial conflicts related to Lebanon.  Lastly, there
are roughly four key points regarding how the nuclear issue will be handled, but actually,
from a market perspective, just
like the oil prices I mentioned earlier, the details of Hormuz's operations
seem to be quite important.  Moving forward, while
hormone trade and nuclear inspections are still at a
stage where implementation verification is needed, if
expectations for trade normalization grow, concerns about crude oil
supply disruptions will decrease, which
could act as downward pressure on oil prices.  So, going forward, the
key point of view will likely be not whether Hormuzhu
opens or not, but rather
under what conditions it opens. That could
become the tracking point
.  As for corporate news, there are
one or two companies below with special positive news or earnings announcements, so I will
mention them briefly, but for now, I think I can say that
damage to the fundamentals of AI memory companies has not been confirmed
.  So, setting the premise that fundamental
damage has not been confirmed, let's
examine the corporate-level issues. Earlier, while discussing
the sectors, I
mentioned that defensive sectors have risen
.  First of all, there were no stocks that hit a new high
.  And among
companies with a market capitalization of over 25 billion,
not a single stock rose today.   The
center of the overall decline was clearly
semiconductors and AI infrastructure; if you
look at the Big Tech sector first,
both Microsoft and Amazon stocks have
fallen.  Now, if we look at
why Microsoft rose,
rather than attributing it to AI-related factors, the
selling pressure today was on the semiconductor sector.
Therefore, it seems more accurate to say that Microsoft was
able to rise not because it performed well, but because the selling target was different.
Conversely, regarding the memory stocks I mentioned yesterday as profit-making companies,
Micron and
SanDisk have fallen.
And Western Digital also
fell by about 8% yesterday, continuing its downward trend
.  Equipment stocks have also been
pushed back.  And if you look at the middle section, the
optical sector continues to reflect a lot of future earnings,
and
Coilant and Lumentum also fell by 10% and 7%, respectively
.
Also, well, I keep talking about it in terms of units,
but space sex was also a somewhat
important psychological indicator.   With
the issue of large-scale unsecured bond issuance emerging yesterday, it seems that
the fact that even cash-sufficient companies are utilizing debt has
spread anxiety regarding AI infrastructure investment and cash flow
.
Uh, the Vice President will probably
give a brief explanation later, but
Cerebros AI, the company that was
announced as a public offering shareholder last time, has
announced its first earnings since listing
.  Sales and annual guidance
were better than expected, but
regarding infrastructure, the key metric the Vice President focuses on is
cross margin.
So, regarding that part, guidance was
presented somewhat conservatively, and it seems to have
shown a somewhat unfavorable trend over time.
Also, Carnival Cruise
announced its earnings.  Likewise, while the earnings
themselves were somewhat better than expected,
the guidance
fell short of market expectations, causing the stock price to drop about 5% during the trading session
.
So, to wrap up today's market, I would
say that rather than a complete sell-off, it was a market where investors sought a safe haven. It was a market where
funds that had been excessively concentrated in AI and semiconductors began to
flee to defensive sectors and quality large-cap stocks.
So, considering that Bau
failed to maintain its gains in the final moments, while
there was a safe haven, it was
n't a market for confident bargain buying.
Therefore, it seems the situation can be summarized as Micron likely to face a heavy burden following its announcement after the market closes today
.  That's all.
thank you  Earlier, our Yuri Pro
introduced an analyst who explained the semiconductor industry and Hynix natively. Yes, rather
than just talking big,
looking at an analyst's past tone is
very helpful in predicting the weight of their current statements. Therefore, I
think it is quite important to review their past reports or interviews to understand their usual tone and stance.  [Snoring] In that
regard, I found what you said to be a bit more
trustworthy and informative.
I usually make
sure to check oil prices, interest rates, and the dollar index whenever you tell me about the first page of our price chart.
[Snorting] Oil prices and interest rates are
generally in a positive
direction for the stock market, but hasn't the dollar index gone
into a neutral phase where it doesn't seem to be dropping below 100
?  I have a feeling that this happened because expectations for interest rate cuts have
completely vanished
.   We will take a closer
look at the US market with Vice President Choi Ho in this section.
Then, let's move on to virtual [clears throat] property
.  Junhyeok, how did it turn out
?   yes
.  I will speak about the counting.   I
briefly mentioned Gasan Assets yesterday, stating that it was
falling along with issues related to the private equity market, but it turns out there were
various other reasons behind that.
So, I think I can introduce those parts together, and
actually,
Bitcoin dropped first yesterday.  Yesterday
in the Asian market, it already broke through $63,000 and
came down, so you can consider it to be trading in the high $62,000 range
.
Since I couldn't cover Monday's market, to
briefly summarize it:
on Monday, Stredy
bought an additional 500 or so Bitcoins.  And
along with that, the
atmosphere regarding the US war was easing a bit, and as things
moved in that direction, the price surpassed $65,000
.  Since then, the
private equity market issue also emerged yesterday, and although
I was unable to grasp the details of that issue early yesterday morning, there was a
Trump executive order regarding quantum computers
.  As those factors
overlapped simultaneously, the trend of Bitcoin prices
worsened.  You can
view it as having returned to the $62,000 level.
Ultimately, since the trend lines and resistance
lines are not straight lines but rather
slightly diagonal, they tend to move
sideways and come down
slightly over time.  So, we end
up drawing a picture that slopes downward to the right, to the bottom.  In that case,
the price will gradually
decrease as it encounters the resistance line.  Uh, considering those factors, please keep in mind that the
resistance is
n't fixed at $66,000, but could drop gradually over time, perhaps to $65,000
or $64,000
.  Uh, you just
explained Dalnes, and
technically speaking, and just
looking at the section connecting the highs, I
personally think that Dalnes might be breaking out of the box range right now.  So,
when connecting the highs, around 101 is
located right at that resistance line.   For
example, if it breaks through that resistance line, it
rises to around the 108 index level, and since that is an open zone, wouldn't this
not be a situation where risky assets are particularly preferred
?  I would say that it doesn't seem like a particularly good environment, especially for a place like Bitcoin
.
If you look at the Bitcoin chart, the Grady Index, it is currently being maintained in the twilight zone
.  Oh,
net outflows from Bitcoin ETFs aren't that great either
.
Since there has been an outflow of about 68 million dollars, it continues to
record a negative weakness. You can
consider it roughly like that.  Uh, I
just explained the Dollar Index, but
uh, when I looked at the Dollar Index on a long-
term chart of about 5 years,
uh, I compared it with gold, Bitcoin, and just the
Dollar Index like this
.  The white line is the dollar index.
Uh, you can think of the orange line as Bitcoin and the
blue line as gold
.
If you look at the right quadrant, you might think that the
rise in Bitcoin and the Dollar Index isn't
very related to the rise in Bitcoin and gold.
However, as I was coming here this morning, I felt that we actually need to divide this in half and look at the left and
right sides separately
.
Because, regarding the Bitcoin price on the right, if you
look at the early part of the ETF market, there was a surge in supply and demand as soon as the Bitcoin spot
market was initially approved
.
Since there has been a continuous rally for 18 months after the halving, I
thought it was necessary to distinguish between the good and bad seasons of Bitcoin.  Well, if we look at it that way, it would actually be more
accurate to say that the one on the right has a weaker correlation with the dollar index.  If
you look at the left side, you can see that during periods when the dollar index is
rising, the bit price does
not show significant strength.
I think you can view it as the seasonal effect and the dollar index overlapping.  Around 2022, as
the price of Bitcoin hit a peak and began to decline,
and as the Federal Reserve
significantly raised interest rates, the dollar
surged, and it seems you can observe
Bitcoin continuing its weakness during that period
.  That trend
continued to have a significant impact on the dollar index until around 2023—that is, up until the moment we saw Bitcoin hit bottom from its peak to its lowest point
.  I thought it would be better to interpret it as being heavily influenced
.  So, I think we
can view this section similarly
.  Personally, I think it might be correct to view it this way: there is a very high probability that Bitcoin will continue to show an unfavorable trend as seasonality overlaps with the Bitcoin Dollar Index, until the Dollar Index
rises and maintains a high level
.  So, we need to look at the right and
left quadrants separately.
If seasonal factors and the rise in the dollar index overlap, I think it would be best to view the price of Bitcoin and gold
not as good, in fact
.  Oh, the one on
the right is the issue
related to quantum computers that I mentioned earlier
.  So,
I wrote that it threatens Bitcoin administratively, and this was an
issue that came out yesterday morning.
Yesterday, President Trump
signed two executive orders regarding quantum computers
.  Uh, 25414411
and 251449 are said to be
executive orders with two codes. The first is for the
private and academic sectors to cooperate to
deploy quantum computers powerful enough to perform scientific research by 2028.  And secondly,
there were two executive orders instructing government security experts to prepare for quantum systems capable of performing standard encryption faster than expected.
So, I remember that the trend for quantum computer-related
companies was
very good in yesterday's
market
.  In reality, if quantum computers
develop significantly, while the
early
Bitcoin itself cannot be hacked, the
possibility of the wallets storing it being hacked
becomes extremely high.  I mentioned this once before when I was
talking about Google, but since the
emergence of quantum computers makes
early wallets somewhat risky, I
personally thought that this might have acted as a negative sentiment for Bitcoin, so I brought these two points
together.  I have explained the dollar index and
quantum laws.  If you look at the main section,
I jokingly wrote the title like, "Is Exam Parallel the number one cryptocurrency instructor?"  I believe I mentioned once that Sean
Farrell, the strategy part head of internal reports at Fundrett where Tom Lee is working, received attention late last year when he
predicted a bear market while Tom Lee was consistently forecasting a bull market, and
that prediction accurately led to the
correction
.
Tom Lee will continue to speak strongly in December
.  I will immediately
disprove it.  Even though I explained it this way,
internally, we are in a section where we are unable to communicate with each other, with the
wheel
saying things differently
.  I have mentioned before that we haven't been able to find a direction
.
That section actually
turned out exactly as Sean Ferrell said.  So, if you
look at the photo on the left, you can see the red box here, which indicates in the report sent to internal clients that there is a
very high probability that Bitcoin will fall to around $60,000 to $65,000 in the base case during the first quarter, and that there is a
very high probability that Ethereum will drop to around $1,800
.
I think we will be able to confirm that we have come exactly to this section.  Rather than feeling like Sean
Farrell accurately predicted the price and
manipulated the market, the
documents actually sent internally to clients contained such content.
At the time, Sean Farrell clarified that Tom Lee
speaks to investors worldwide, whereas he
sends messages to clients with a high proportion of cryptocurrency, so the wording might be slightly
different
.  So, I think you can take those points into
consideration, and at that time,
[clearing one's throat] there
was also a prediction like this.  You
can look at the picture on the right here.  Here, in these
various sections, there is hope,
positivity, and trust
.  Here we are in the interval with N.
So,
mentioning that Bitcoin is currently entering a state of slight anger after hitting a peak and falling, he
predicted these two things at that time.  The price of Bitgong will
drop to a certain level.  And
since we are currently in an angle zone, they predicted that the correction will continue a little longer in this state
.  Then, I think
we need to take another look at how the test panel is viewing this now
.  I also gave a price forecast
.  Uh, I mentioned that while it won't
plummet to extreme levels like the previous Bitcoin bear market, there is a
possibility of a drop to around $48,000 to $52,000, even though current investors are strongly supported by demand. I am
referring to the difference between the last realized price at which Bitcoin moved based on the MBRB and the actual price currently being displayed.  He explained that even based on that standard, if the
average price of Bitcoin
drops to around $53,000, it would be
worth actively buying
.  Uh, he also mentioned that it is positive that
market leverage has been significantly reduced due to recent liquidations
.  And actually, since explaining that these parts are
areas with little demand even in the middle ground is
similar to the angle, I
thought that explaining that there is a bias toward the opposite side is the same as the monster.   They
also mentioned the risks associated with microstage and strategy stretch.   It was
explained that the risk of a sustained crash in Strategy, which was a concern in the market, appears to have been significantly alleviated in the short term. The company is
showing efforts to expand its cash reserves through capital raising, and I believe the probability of the company immediately
selling a large amount of Bitcoin is
low.  However, they
added this important final sentence: "There is no clear catalyst visible that has led to a strong influx into the cryptocurrency ecosystem in the short term."  While macro analysis
suggests that inflation caused by the war is
highly likely to be temporary, indicators such as the core CPI could continue to rise in the short term
.  They mentioned that the bond market is already
reflecting the possibility of a September rate hike,
and that rather than the actual hike, it is an environment where
various risk assets, including cryptocurrencies,
could lose momentum in the short term amidst the Fed's tone shifting toward hawkishness or the bond market testing the new Fed chair
.  So, I
think there are three possibilities, but ultimately, it seems the
weakness in Bitcoin will continue for a while
.  And that test can
go from $48 to $52,000
.  However,
Strategy mentioned that such an environment is unlikely to occur as they sell off a large volume of Bitcoin, and ultimately, it seems he was saying that risks like cryptocurrencies could be threatened amidst the continuing spread of fear that
Kevin might raise interest rates in the macro environment
.  So, this
is the MBRB chart that was mentioned earlier.
There is the data provided by Fidelity on the left.  So, if you look at the ratio between the
actual average
price and the displayed price based on MBRB standards, and it
drops to around 1 or 0, you
can understand that this is a range where the value is somewhat undervalued
.  Anyway, in terms of that section, it has
come down quite a bit now.
Since it is in the 53,000 range, it has
dropped significantly to that level.
I think you can interpret it roughly like this.
So, ultimately, will Mr. Keviner definitely raise interest rates now
?  I
brought this because I thought it would be good for me to take a quick look at it. Mr. [Name] mentioned that he would look at the trimmed
inflation rate,
trimmed average, and PC
.  So, if we
look at the truncated average PC rate, based
on the A-Fred standard,
it appears to be gradually decreasing
.
So, when the inflation rate
rose to almost 5% in 2022, it has been
showing a picture of gradually coming down since then.  You can view the
top 31%, which is referred to as the absolute average, as simply the
figure obtained by arbitrarily cutting off the top
.  The one right
below is the
general current interest rate situation for the US 2-year bond,
and the one right below that is the
inflation rate.  I interpreted the inflation
gap as roughly the fact that investors are placing bets on
how much inflation is likely to rise in the future
.  So, the
blue chart at the top is the 2-year dollar, and the
yellow chart at the bottom
is the inflation total.  So, while
we have been continuously
tracking the trend of the 2-year inflation rate actually rising significantly, it does not seem that the inflation rate is
rising that much
.
So, rather than
showing a pattern of peaking and then turning downward, if you
look at the search chart below, and examine the actual
government bond yields,
FundsTrade has
forecasted that the trend is still falling slightly short of 2%.
So, ultimately, what Farrell is trying to say is that in
this process where the Fed Chairman is testing the market, if Kevin
Kevin concludes from earnings that the current rise in inflation is due to real growth rather than inflation, then there is a
very high probability that in the second quarter, instead of raising interest rates, a slightly more accommodative and dovish policy will be implemented.  If that happens, they
predicted that there is a high probability that both cryptocurrencies and risky assets will improve slightly in the second half of the year.  So, if you scroll down and
look, I've written something like "26-Year
Virtual Charity Outlook, Just for Fun."
They predicted that Bitcoin might recover to around $115,000 and Ethereum to around $44,500 by the end of the year.  So, based
on the $53,000 benchmark, they
predicted that it would show a growth rate of over 100% by the end of the year.   In
the end, it is the promised month of October again.  So, since the
current outlook is that things will improve in the second half of the year, if the
data regarding interest rates and inflation that Sean Farrell mentioned is accurate,
I believe that inflation is not currently high enough to warrant an aggressive interest rate hike.  Anyway, regarding
how it is implemented and proceeded,
practically speaking, Kevin
doesn't make decisions based solely on PC trends,
so while it is
highly likely that this is the case when considering that aspect, I
think there is a need to review other aspects as well.
Anyway, I accurately forecasted this market last December, and I
wanted to let you know how the market looked going forward, so I
mentioned it.  That's all.
thank you  Even if you are not directly investing in Bitcoin or Ethereum, there was
a lot to learn today, such as the dollar index and interest rate outlooks. It was very helpful that you explained the
logical foundations behind those decisions and movements
in detail
.  I will take another look as well
.  As I
host the first part of the Morning Brief, I notice that when volatility
increases and the stock market falls, many
more people are watching during the official broadcast time
.  I see today that there are
over 1,350 people.  Ah, since the market is
quite volatile, I imagine you are interested and
worried, so I will
wrap up here, hoping you can take away more from this part.
Thank you to all the channels that joined us.
Hm.
เฮ
[Music]
Hello.  We will begin the second part of the program for the Honghan Investment Journey
with Investment Manager Chae So-ri, Charlie Money Reaver,
today, Wednesday, June 24.
[Clears throat]
Now, the broadcasting market is large, and if you look at the US market, it is
growing in the US market because of the market.  It feels like this.  Yes,
that is correct.  It feels like if the Korean market
gets orders, the US market gets orders too, and if the Korean
market rises, the US market rises as well
.  The reason is that the
key stocks leading the recent global market are concentrated in Korea and the U.S., and it
seems these phenomena are appearing because the semiconductor sector, in particular, has a significant impact.  Actually, looking at the
performance of individual and institutional investors this year, it
seems that success or failure varies drastically depending on how they invested in and managed their semiconductor stocks.  So, when I meet with existing individual
investors, I see that those who
held onto the M7 for several years performed
reasonably well until 2025, but are seeing
poor results in 2026. On
the other hand,
those who successfully managed their portfolios with semiconductors are seeing
quite good results, so it
seems we are experiencing a polarization.  I
think it will be the same for me in the future.  So,
how you view this decline and
how you respond to it
seems like it will be a significant factor.  If I
start right away.  I
think the key is the number of weeks.  Just as Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix are key players in our country
.  However, as
I continue to
check the EPS and valuation of the Philippine Index, there has
been a pattern in the past where, when the valuation of the Philippine Index reaches a peak level, the price also hits a historical high and a correction occurs.  And
for various reasons—such as a
war between the U.S., Japan, and Korea, rising oil prices and interest rates,
or concerns regarding the SpaceX IPO—
whenever the market fell, the valuation was always at a peak level
.  Such
trends appeared again this time. As of the 22nd, the
P/E ratio of the general index rose to 29.3 times, reaching a level of 3 times. If you
look at the chart previously, the yellow line represents the
general index's P/E ratio; it had
previously
recorded a high of around 28.8 times, but this time it
surpassed 28.8 times and
went up to 29 times. As the index itself reached a new high, there was
clearly a valuation burden as well
.
Furthermore, with Samsung
Electronics and SK Hynix in the Korean market, as well as
somewhat aggressive forecasts regarding future interest rate hikes
emerging from BOFA, the
decline is explained by various reasons. Ultimately, I think it appears to be a complex combination of factors, including market concentration,
price pressure, and valuation
burden
.  So, after
listening for a long time, we often see drops of around 10%,
while on the other hand, we also see short-term increases of 10%; I
consider this to be a natural phenomenon that occurs in overheated zones.   I
continue to update recent correction cases;
last March, there was a
drop of about 10% over three days due to the U.S.-Japan-South Korea war
.  There were instances in May where it dropped by about
6.4% over two days, though not by 10%
.
Also, in early June, there were instances where the market fell by
2.2% and 10.3% on the 4th and 5th, dropping from 12.2% over two days. At
that time, there
was talk of interest rate impacts or concerns regarding the SpaceX listing.
Yesterday, the
general index fell by 7.9% from its peak, and
I view this as a result of short-term overheating or valuation burdens.  So,
amidst such sharp fluctuations in June,
what is the current state of the Philippine Index
?  Looking at June alone, the
growth rate recorded an increase of about 5.1%
.  SMP 500
-2.8%, Nasdaq -5.1%, Cell
1.9%, Dow 1.2%. I also
noted the KOSPI for reference, which
is at the -3.2% level.  So,
looking at June alone, it was the strongest among the major indices, but
individual stocks
were even stronger while the index rose by 5.1%.  With Micron
up 8.3% and 3%,
ASML, Lam Research, Applied
Materials, and Mott have risen by 10% to 30%.   With
Intel rising 15%, Marvell
Technology 36%, and storage device
giants like SanDisk, Wesson Digital, and
C-Gate
rising by 10% to over 20%, I believe there was clearly a
price burden on these stocks.
This
price pressure manifested as a concentration of investment, and a stark
contrast is evident in the fact that if you
look at other large-cap stocks in June,
there isn't a single M7 stock that posted a gain.  They are all dropping from the mid-to-high single digits
to double digits
.  So, you can view this as extreme polarization and extreme
polarization
appearing in the semiconductor index and the stocks within it. As for other
major stocks in the old economy, which are somewhat ambiguous here, they are holding up
reasonably well.
In particular, financial stocks such as JP Morgan,
Banker Bonica, and
Morgan Stanley showed upward trends ranging
from the high single digits to double digits. Additionally,
Illy, known as a defensive stock, rose by about 0.2%, Johnson
& Johnson by 6.1%, and other stocks
directly or indirectly related to AI infrastructure, such as
Caterpillar (12.4%) and
United (7.6%)
.  So, to define the US market
in June,
Big Tech was completely wiped out, semiconductors were
very good, and in the middle, high-economy
defensive stocks literally held their own.
I think we can still see it like this.  I think that Mycon Technallo, which is coming out today after the
US market
closes, will be able to
make this trend even clearer once again
.  So,
when looking at the fluctuations by stock, as I mention every time, we
frequently
observe phenomena where the general index rises like a single stock. Even within this, we see that those with
stronger momentum rise more, while those with
weaker momentum rise less
.  Yesterday, we observed
double-digit declines mainly in stocks that had risen sharply,
while
stocks that had risen less
fell less.
So, Micron
fell by about 13%, mainly due to memory, and in the storage sector,
SanDisk, West Digital, and
Seagate also
dropped by single or double digits.
Equipment stocks had been performing quite well, but a decline of about
9% for Lam Research and 8% for Applied Materials
was observed.
Looking at the fluctuation rates for June, even though it fell yesterday, you
can see that within the general index, there are still many stocks with strong momentum that have risen above the investment level, as I mentioned earlier.
And I looked at some
indicators to check when that sharp drop occurred
.  So, the main topic of discussion in the market right now
is the controversy surrounding future interest rate hikes, but
for now, oil prices, which are stimulating inflation, have
currently dropped to $73
.
Since there is currently progress in the negotiations with Iran, I think prices might come down a bit further. However,
some
argue that prices might not drop easily because it will take a long time to restore production facilities. Ultimately, I
believe that stock prices tend to move upwards, so given the
current
situation, I do not think oil prices will be a major issue
.  The 10-year bond yield is
fluctuating around 4.5%, and it
seems likely to be affected by future economic or inflation indicators.   The
current consensus for ORPC, which will be announced tomorrow night at 9:30 on the 25th, is
4.1% for the headline and 3.4% for the core.
Compared to the previous day, the headline is expected to rise by 0.3 percentage
points and the core by 0.1% to 1 percentage
point. However, if
Micron Technology's
earnings report comes out well tomorrow morning at 5 AM, I think the
PC consensus PC
price index to be announced on the night of the 25th might just be a passing indicator
.  Since oil prices were already high in May anyway, I
think the market will likely tolerate and move past any further increases as long as they match the market's strength.  And, according to US time,
Mycon Technologies' earnings will be announced after our market closes on the 24th.
Yesterday, it hit a new high compared to its previous high, then
fell by about 13.2%, almost going up
tenfold
.  It fell 13% yesterday, and is
currently trading at 9.6 times
.  Based on total production, the
consensus for the May quarter is 81.8%, and the total production rate is 8%.  And uh, the
gross sales ratio for the second quarter is set to
rise slightly by 5% to 83.5%, and I
think that part will be the key point.  Last time as well, there was
some talk regarding the gross profit margin, and a
situation occurred where the stock price dropped immediately after the earnings announcement.
So, how that part is presented is
important. Generally, I
think they will discuss it, but since the
consensus is already quite high, we'll have to wait and see if they actually do.
Personally,
looking at the circumstances, I view it positively.   There is
some talk coming out regarding the annual funds rate, and yesterday
in the Korean market,
news flow emerged suggesting that Bankern could raise rates three times in separate batches this year based on research data. It turns out that the
data
released by Bankern regarding the three rate hikes this year was announced on the morning of the 22nd, New York
time
.
So, this
is data from about two days ago.  However, since the market
fell yesterday, this data was actually released before the market opened on the 22nd in the US market. It did
n't have much impact on the market on the 22nd, but as the Korean market dropped yesterday, this
data received some attention. Bank of
America's claim is that they could raise interest rates by 25 percentage points in September, October, and
December
.  As for the basis of that claim,
I was unable to obtain the original text, so I summarized it based only on an
article from the Wall Street Journal. They
argue that due to solid economic indicators and the Fed's stance being more hawkish than expected, they are likely to raise interest rates about three times.   But
in this house, that flow material
comes out every week.  And
the
fund major Serway, which comes out once a month, has been
continuously presenting contrarian strategies regarding that market since the second half of last year
.  So, my
feeling is that
these points were presented based on grounds that can support the contrarian strategy
.  The
reason I think that is that
when looking at the frequency or timing of interest rate hikes estimated by Padwatch following the FMC, the FMC meeting
on July 29th is expected to
result in a freeze.  It is listed as 62.6% and 6% environmentally, and an
increase starting September 16, 2026, but
the probability of it increasing to 50% and 5% is not very high
.  In my opinion, all the
situations and circumstances up until that point need to be
reflected as well
.  And while the
market is currently making these
expectations based solely on the Fed's Hokkien stance at the FMC, I think we need to continue observing
how oil prices continue to affect inflation and how
economic indicators turn out. Given the
current situation, I think three times is a bit
excessive.   I've
been watching the peer index for a while now, and
recently,
even though the stock price has been rising, there has been a
continuous peer area.
Yesterday, as the
overall U.S. market itself worsened, I did
shift a bit further toward extreme tiers
.  So, looking at the current situation, it is
recording around 28. If you
look at the S&P 500 and the N-Leads Index next to it, the
S&P 500 is the red line and the N-Leads
Index is the blue line.
Previously, they seemed to
move together, but this time,
despite the divergence being in the peer area, the S&P 500 is
rising, which is a somewhat unusual
occurrence. Ultimately, this reflects how skewed the indicators composing the grid index are and what level government bond yields are currently at, so it has now entered the peer area.
In particular, it seems that it has reached a negative impact regarding the bias phenomenon
.  But anyway, based on that experience
and pattern, the further you go into the peer
area, especially the external peer
area, the
lower the risk becomes—as I always say.  So, I am telling you that if you
respond with a split-buying perspective, you can achieve decent results
when the market normalizes over time
.  This time as well, I am simply
structuring my portfolio well with core stocks,
and I believe that if those who haven't had the opportunity to
rebalance now do so, it could
lead to decent results
.  And
if you look at VIXX, since the stock prices
fell significantly yesterday, it is currently in a
situation where it has risen to around 19.5.  I'm not sure if it will go up further or not, but it is
currently in a state of overheating to some extent. Since the
valuation burden has been
somewhat alleviated by the sharp decline, and
because I expect Mycon Technology's earnings to come out positive, I do
n't think these parts will be recovered
.  So, I have
pointed out various factors, including the previous drop in the Philippine Index, the current situation of the Index, the overall US market situation, and Necro issues. In
conclusion, I believe this is a process of semiconductor over-reliance and
overheating of price valuations.
Since the market has already undergone a pre-adjustment prior to Micron's earnings announcement, I think the
Micron earnings report to be released tomorrow at 5 AM next year will serve as a
turning point for recovering the losses
.  That's all.   yes
.  thank you
My husband said it happened first yesterday, and
now that it is even affecting the US market,
many people are doing it.
That US lab became Senate last week and
is recruiting now.
yes.  Recruitment.
Recruitment is open until Friday.  We
plan to begin operations starting next Monday.   Just like
yesterday, weapons were
covered by rain last week, and
anyway, I put good stocks out cheaply.
Of course.  Because the more that happens, the
higher the upside potential becomes.
yes.
But since stocks are a
shared asset,
yes.   In
my case, when trying to adjust this short passage, the gap goes down to about 135 verses, so I thought, "
Ah, the adjustment is correct."
But nobody knows if the gap will go up to 130
.   That's right
.  yes.  you're right.  It might
go that way, and it might drop out again at some point, but in a
way, through this,
we conveyed to both the domestic and U.S. sides last week and are
dropping out.  If you look into it, regarding
that part, I'm
not sure if you are extending the microphone properly according to the planned drawing, but
yes, please do it like this.   I
think I can just briefly explain it like this, but so, to
reiterate what I said about that short-term volatility,
it is luck.  Honestly, I try to match it,
but it's a matter of luck.  So,
fortunately last week, we
liquidated all our target conversions for both domestic and US labs, and recruitment is
starting this week. Some
companies are starting next week as well.
I even mentioned on Pokai or Gostopan that we should avoid the lucky ones, but
[clears throat]
fortunately, since we run a channel where we share what we've studied—like doing a morning
briefing every day and releasing special editions—I do
actually think that perhaps that is why luck is working out so well for us
.
So, ultimately, there are two things. The
first is that you absolutely have to build a good portfolio,
right?
yes.  Does the boss emphasize strength?  First of all, you need to build a
good portfolio. If you
read Pete Lynch's older books, he
mentioned that because he builds his portfolio around turnaround stocks and high-growth stocks, his returns are significantly better than the market.  You mentioned [clearing throat] that because beta is
high, it drops sharply compared to the market when it
falls and rises sharply when it rises. The market is
concentrated in good stocks, and while this
concentration is fine if you are investing only with your own money,
hatch funds
use a lot of leverage—taking long positions with much larger quantities than your own capital and borrowing shares to buy stocks they consider bad. As a result, when
good stocks drop, they inevitably face a stop-loss
situation. Similarly, when
individual investors using margin trading experience a
sharp decline in good stocks, forced
selling occurs. Since this is a
factor that causes volatility, those who
do not use leverage might wonder
why the market is acting so erratically, going up and
down so drastically. However, to
understand this aspect, I went to conduct proprietary
trading. Vice President Choi also visited a brokerage firm to do proprietary trading in the past, and even in
such houses, there are things like monthly stop-loss management.
So, if you have invested in a good stock, if it
drops below a certain level, you have to mechanically
sell it again.  Those
parts... ah, so this is what makes us
talk about volatility.
Regular mutual funds don't
do it that way.  I see that the volatility of stocks is appearing so severely due to leveraged investors who use a lot of credit, such as those involved in free trading,
hatch funds, and CFD
accounts
.  yes.  I came to understand that part a bit
.  Then, since it becomes an opportunity to buy good stocks cheaply when those players are forced to
sell at a low price, if you
understand that well, in our
case, we are recruiting this week.
yes.  He is refraining from doing this this time.
So, it seems like we are being
given the opportunity to buy good stocks at such a low price, which is
truly working out well for us
.  yes.  I am thinking that
.  Now, but uh, why are you leaving out now of all times
?  Why is it being dropped right now of all times
? We need to think about this part now
.  yes.
Regarding that aspect, as I mentioned recently, the
listing of a giant like SpaceX certainly plays a role, but ultimately, the
biggest fear for those leveraged investors is having their positions forcibly liquidated if the market collapses
.  So, I am going to do a lot of
studying in my own way, but as I
explained right before, when did this great help
come?   I
looked to see when that happened, and it seems that whenever the Fed chairman is
replaced, there is a correction.
But when I looked into that, I realized that just because the
Fed Chairman was replaced, it was
n't always an adjustment. It depends on whether it came during a period of
falling or rising interest rates. I
thought it came while rates were falling, but then
Allen Griese took
office in August 1987 and raised rates in September, only for
Blackman Day to follow in October. Since there have been several such incidents,
from their perspective, whether it
comes out on Padwatch now or not, they are saying it is one,
two, or three rate hikes
.  Hey, since this is
n't a historical case from the past and I didn't get bitten, right now, in
a way, there is a bit of a gray nostril up
ahead, and regarding whether it will come running or not, for
someone investing my money, it does
n't matter.  It doesn't matter if you run.   It will
drop and then fully recover anyway
.  However, from the perspective of players using leverage, if the dilution
swells even just close to that point, it gets installed in the market and
wipes out all the positions of the bettors, so for them, this
current
situation is a market that is making things quite wide
.  So recently, we are
seeing stocks that are not performing well collapsing like a crash, and the same goes for the coin market, which
best indicates investor sentiment toward risk
.   The
coin market also appears to be collapsing.
So yesterday morning, I said that honestly, we have
entered a bear market, and it could be a
bear market that lasts for about 3 or 4 months
.  The reason I said that is, for us who don't use leverage, is an interest rate
hike really that
important?
But for players who use leverage, it is
one of the scariest things.
So there is such an adjustment, and fortunately, both the
SP 500 and
our KOSPI currently have
very favorable PRs and multiples.
Because the multiples are good, that is why we went through
another gap adjustment at 130 this time as well. Back then, it
surpassed 130 on February 27th, but then
dropped 20% in one fell swoop. As soon as the gap adjustment
ended, it hit a double bottom and came
back up, didn't it?
This time too, we see a similar form and some technical
adjustments, but those leveraged
players are now... uh... aggressive... ah, it's
over now.  Now, as we say that Koplso came over there and is
going back,
we have to think about when he will return. When will he come back
?  When will you come back?  July
29.  Ah, are
n't they raising interest rates here?  Then September
16th.  Yes. Because of this part,
those leveraged players wo
n't be able to return until the end of July
.  In my opinion, they won't be able to enter the market, and as for when I think they will
return,
the situation where interest rate hikes are inevitable is that they were recently hit at 2.4% and
rose to 4.2%. If you look at the CPI, if
prices continue to rise,
Europe has raised rates, Japan has raised them, and
Korea will raise them as well. Therefore, the
central bank is now entering into tightening measures not so much because of Micron's earnings, but because of the [snorting] side of rising prices
.  Then, I will raise the pad as well due to the tightening
.  I will upload it to let you know, but it is
okay if I upload it on July 29th.  It’s okay to raise it, but if we move into August and
September, the June
CPI is released in July, you know.
yes.
But regarding June, I watched the US World Cup matches
yesterday, and in the highlights, even though Argentina was
playing against Jordan, the stadium in San Francisco was
packed with spectators.  Uh, well, it’s
not even a popular country, but it was packed.
Looking at that, I thought, "Ah,
during the world-class period in June, the supply is
solid and prices won't drop
."  Then, regarding the
June inflation figures to be announced in July,
the numbers won't be high enough to justify not raising interest rates
.  But the July prices announced in August are
a bit... well, now that the
World Cup is over.  yes.  And as for the
August CPI to be announced in September,
oh ah, it's turning downwards... ah, it is turning downwards
.  With employment
showing signs of decline, I actually get
the feeling that the usual adjustments in September and October came a bit earlier this time due to the World Cup and the CPI figures
.  Normally, stocks
undergo significant adjustments around September and October.  Yeah, yeah.
So, adjust it for a month or two and come a bit sooner.
Rather, by September and October, we see a
clear downward trend in the CPI and a
deterioration in employment. Because of this,
interest rates cannot be raised at all, so it is
acceptable to raise them twice by September 16th.  From what I saw, you
could upload it twice, but you can't
upload it anymore.  The news that it couldn't be raised any further
gave investors some confidence, and from
then on, the rally started again.
Uh, I am thinking that now
.
So, for
those who have been relatively relieved this past one or two or three months, yes.   There are quite a few
people who feel a great sense of loss because they cannot buy stocks.
Such people can buy good stocks at a low price
.  A very good season.  And
as you showed us, the market capitalization of Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix has already reached 4,000 trillion
.
That is correct.
So, since this big brother of 4,000 trillion is pulling this much forward, I
told you that the younger brothers of the Middle Ages Hongju would eventually follow suit.  The younger siblings will follow suit, but they wo
n't be able to keep up in a phase where interest rates are rising
.  That's right.  So, this interest rate
ended at around 2000.  The
exact person who taught that was Northern
Qi, the creator of the spirit world
.  When September comes, and as we transition from September to
October, credit government bond
yields drop sharply to 4.2, 4.0, and 3.8,
yes.  I think that by doing so, it gives a
signal that the younger siblings can follow along now
.  So, for those of
you who are only trading stocks, you can just close your account completely and go
travel and have fun for three months
.  Just leave it covered up for 3 months
.  But for those who don't have stocks or things
like that, check out our Chaesley TV.   If
you look at the timing carefully, I think you just need to aim for it. I think the
entry point might be around the end of July or August
.  So then, let's
move on to the domestic market. Yes, I will
start with the previous day.   The
hospice plummeted by nearly 10%
.  The Horse Daq
recorded a significant drop of about 8%.   If
you take a look, individual investors were
seen absorbing all the selling from foreign and institutional investors by making spot purchases worth 8.5 trillion won.  Foreign investors sold around 4
trillion won, and institutions
sold a significant amount of about 4.5 trillion won.  In the futures
market, foreign investors were consistently selling during the session,
but it appears they shifted to buying after the market closed
.
Looking at external trends by investor type, foreign investors
bought LG Innotek.
Other than that, I purchased MiraeSet, Samsung Electro-Mechanics, Hyundai
Mobis, HD, Hyundai Heavy Industries, Busan, etc.
Foreign selling included approximately
2.6 trillion won in SK Hynix sales
.  And
there was a sale of SK Square worth 1.1 trillion won.  Other than that, I
sold Hyundai Motor, Samsung Electronics preferred shares, Samsung C&T, etc. Institutional buying included
DB HiTek, Samyang Foods, Korea
Aerospace Industries, and Hyosung Heavy Industries, while selling involved
approximately 3.8 trillion won and
3.9 trillion won in stocks such as SK Inix and Samsung Electronics
.  Other than that, they
were ETF stocks.   The number of
stocks hitting a 52-week high has
decreased significantly.  There are five stocks, and they are
all small-cap companies.
On the KOSPI, there is Bohae, a subsidiary of the steel industry;
on the Bosdaq, there are JW Pharmaceuticals, etc. It was
difficult to report them.
Does the National Pension Service have to sell its stocks?   There
seems to be some talk that we need to sell now [clear our throats], but
nothing has been decided exactly.   Did you
actually start selling?  Or
the article says that some were sold
.  Uh, and there is talk that they will start
selling more in earnest from July
.
Ah, starting from July, I began selling about 1.5 trillion won
this month,
and I have to continue selling until mid-July
.  They will probably continue selling about 300 to 400 million won a day
.   yes
.  That's because there are also supply and demand issues,
right?  Uh, recently, foreigners
sold for free yesterday—wait a minute—about 6 trillion won, but here it
shows up as around 4.16 trillion won. Hmm,
hmm.
But I think after it ended, I
was analyzing new cars with about 11 trillion won, and it
came out a bit like that.
So, if you look at the market participants now, the ones pushing it up are
foreigners and institutions, but since
selling is coming out from foreigners and the National Federation of Financial Groups,
and with selling pressure coming from both foreigners and institutions, a
cause for a market correction has arisen, so it looks like it is falling easily.
Also, if you look at foreigners yesterday, remember how they bought
Hynix at double the rate while selling
Hynix the day before yesterday?
Seeing that, [snorting] it is
highly likely that the domestic black-haired people using CFT accounts are domestic CFT accounts.
I printed it out like that, but
as I mentioned, [snorting] the Levridge investment
was too much.  The credit market is about
37 trillion right now, isn't it?
That is correct.  yes.
That is the situation, and so in terms of supply and demand,
selling by the National Pension Service is occurring again
.  All right.
Okay, shall we take a look at the declaration under Article 52?  Oh, there are only five
categories.   I
told you.
Uh, three KOSDAQ stocks, then KOSPI
stocks—there is
n't a single one with a market capitalization of less than 200 million. Yeah, even
among the KOSPI 200 stocks yesterday, there were only
five good ones.   yes yes
.   It's been completely destroyed,
yes.  Now, let's
take a look at the volumes of the major stocks.   yes
.  If you take a look at the semiconductor sector,
major semiconductor stocks
saw a sharp decline yesterday.  I don't think it was omitted due to any particular issue
.  There was some
talk about the inclusion in the MSCI Developed Markets Index falling through, and also, the
Democratic Party argued that
taxes should be collected on realized gains and losses from stocks
.  It seems there were some discussions about real estate and things like that in
the morning session as well.   With the
MSI falling through, I know that the
National Pension Service needs to
sell about 50 trillion won, as you mentioned earlier, but you said that we could expect a supply and demand effect of about
40 trillion won due to the MSI forecast index
.  So, it seems that
some [sneer]
noise regarding whether the available supply has further disappeared had an impact on the market, and the
major semiconductor sector
saw a significant decline of about 12%, with Electronics Enix showing a sharp downward trend.
Among the materials, parts, and equipment stocks listed below,
quite a few showed a decline of more than 10%
.  In the IT sector, Samsung
Electro-Mechanics plummeted 10%, and
stocks such as LG Electronics and LG Innotek also
fell sharply.  The platform sector also generally
saw a significant drop of about 6 to 8%.  The EK Index closed
down about 3.5%.  Torque
Electron 6%, Murata 10%, and the
rebound in Disco Advance... here too, the semiconductor and
IT sectors were showing significant declines
.  In the automotive sector, Hyundai Motor
plummeted 12%, and it seems that
stocks like Kia, Bobis, and AutoEver also fell sharply due to loans
.  So, robot-
related stocks have also been performing very poorly recently
.  It definitely
feels like this trend has accelerated since the FMC, and the
consumer goods sector performed poorly.
Well, it wasn't bad compared to the market, but the
major cosmetics sector
saw a drop of about 2 to 4 percent, and the Pion device sector also
saw a drop of about 4 percent.
As the food and beverage sector below has a somewhat defensive nature, Samyang Foods
closed at roughly flat levels.
KTNG below didn't drop significantly either
.
Department store chains that had risen significantly recently also showed some declines, with
Shinsegi recording a drop of about 6% and Hyundai Department Store about 2%
.
If you look at the shipbuilding, steel, and other sectors,
shipbuilding stocks also showed a significant decline without any particular issues
.  Hyundai Heavy Industries, Hana, and Ocean have each
dropped by 7% and 10%, respectively, and
there are also recommendations to give up on the steel and chemical sectors below.  And the defense industry also
showed a weak trend of around 4%.
With the KOSDAQ performing poorly, the biotech sector also saw most
biotech stocks close lower. Although there were
some brief moments of gains during
the session, the market fell further towards the close, causing the
KOSDAQ biotech sector to collapse along with it
.
And bank and securities stocks generally showed a weak
trend
.   I've noticed there have been some
short reports on securities stocks recently
.  While earnings and
such are all fine, isn't it possible that trading volume has
been picked off to some extent? As a result, the
upside potential of the stock price could be damaged.  It seems like some industry
reports like this have been released recently
.  On the Mentor side,
including HYBE, most of them generally dropped significantly.
Byeon Hak-gi's side also showed a large lead explosion.   Based on
past patterns, if the market is expected to
enter a bear market,
trading volume will certainly decrease.
Consequently,
the profits of brokerage firms, whose main business was brokerage, will
decline, and that pattern of falling stock prices has
been repeated. However,
recently, stock prices have actually
been incredibly strong.  Right?  And
recently, there are
stocks appearing that are falling by as much as 30% from their peaks.  As it comes out, since
we are
closely involved with securities firms, doing wrap accounts and various other things,
we know very well how they conduct business and where they make money. At some point, back when people used to talk about Figaro, a
trading completion occurred during one administration.  Somewhere they say the sale is
free for life... no, it's a
Brokeridge house sale, but
how can it be miraculous without receiving that Brokeridge blood?   They
gathered funds,
earned credit interest through credit, and sold financial products, and it has
largely shifted to actual financial product sales.  Right?
Therefore, while actual transaction volume is certainly
important, a good market leads to an influx of
customers and consequently an
increase in capital. However, with the current
upward trend, our country's financial
assets, which were heavily concentrated in real estate, are
now shifting toward finance. Within finance,
funds that were in banks are now
moving toward the current administration. Since
this fact is being dismissed as an industry undergoing structural growth,
stock prices are not falling based solely on past patterns.
Actually,
Manager Oh just [snorted], "I'll buy you a Paraba
."   I'll
buy you a BMP Parava.   You can
actually just buy it with that kind of feeling.
However, it might be
a bit difficult for those who buy it right now with a plan to use it for a week or a month, but the
price has become reasonable now.  When looking at the
stock market, the truth is, whether in the US or
[clears throat] in Korea, the
quality of the rise itself isn't exactly
good—though it's difficult to judge it the same way
.  Actually, for a stock to become a securities stock, there needs to be
active trading as it forms a theme—like the medieval drinking stocks or the KOSDAQ that retail investors like—but I hear that there is
n't much of that these days.  Since the reality for individual investors is that once they get stuck in a position, they
cannot easily sell and rebalance,
and
because the market is driven mainly by large-cap stocks like Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix, there are assessments that while the trading volume itself is
high, the
trading frequency and environment for individual investors are
not as good as in previous bull markets
.   I know
.
And yesterday, the 'Oh Woman' newspaper tried to cover it but
removed it; now it's a two-level
level.
Only brokerage firms make money because of things like this.  Oh, there is a story like that, too
.  Considering various factors, I wo
n't be investing in US stocks due to the recent correction.  The number of
people investing in US stocks is bound to continue increasing
.
Since there are many people who try to hold a balanced portfolio of domestic and US stocks, I think that
in the case of brokerage firms, even if the market falls, the
companies that will survive for the next 100 years are brokerage firms.   I don't know what will happen to
manufacturers even after 100 years,
but
things like the US Black will still be around after
100 years.
[Snorting] With that
concept in mind, if you look at it from the perspective of what stock you are
buying, what value it has, and
how good a price you are buying it at relative to that value, then a
drop in stock prices is absolutely not a bad thing
.  [Snoring] Okay, then we're going to
look at the report.
Researcher Lee Jae-won of Yuhanta says there is no stock that rises indefinitely every day
.  Uh, that's a funny title.  This was a report that
came out during trading yesterday as the market plummeted
.   The
KOSPI and KOSDAQ plummeted, and the market
sidecar was triggered on both indices.
And it even affected the KOSPI circuit breaker
. While it is said that this situation was
limited to Korea within the Asian stock market, as can be
confirmed by the positive trend in the Asian stock market, the
volatility of macroeconomic indicators was also
positive.  So, even when this report came out,
Nike
was correcting by about 1%.  The RIKEN index
did close up by over 3% towards the end, but it seems the Korean market
fell relatively significantly.  There
were no significant rises in market interest rates or oil prices during the trading session, and the
cause of the correction is attributed to profit-taking selling pressure on large-cap semiconductor stocks
and a technical correction
.  Hynix's stock price has been
rising continuously, continuing a rally to new
highs, and the gap with the moving average has
widened. It has
also entered the overbought zone at 76.2, and
while a technical correction is
possible at any time, it is judged that it is not a trend
.  It is said that no issues were found in the current fundamentals or macroeconomics that
would undermine the KOSPI's upward trend, and that this
can be interpreted as a process of profit-taking selling pressure emerging following the breakout of 5,000, 6,000, 7,000, and 8,000 points.  It would be
necessary to utilize this for low-price buying accounting.  Of course, one could
attach lagging justifications such as caution regarding PCs, concerns about Micron's earnings, or the overall outlook for three rate hikes by BOA this year, but I do not think it is easy to attribute this to
Korea being the only country in Asia to experience such a sharp decline today
.   In
conclusion, it can be seen that it is falling significantly because it has risen a lot, and it is
closer to a request for passage that should appear after breaking through 9.  It is said that
as the KOSPI rose by more than 100% in 2026, a
daily drop of more than 5% consistently
occurred within an average of 6 trading days after the first breakthrough of the index in increments of 1,000 points from 4,000 to 9,000 points.  It is said that the average drop was
around 6%.  I assessed yesterday's
correction
as a quantitative adjustment within the scope and suggested that it was more likely to be a resolution rather than a breakdown of the trend
.  Well, as far as I
remember, whenever it went up by 1,000 points, it would
go from 5,000 to 5,300. When it first broke through 5,000, it went up to 53,400, then dropped sharply for a while, then bounced back up to the high
5s, took a few days of
correction, surpassed 6,000,
went up to 6,300, and then took back down to 6. It has followed this
pattern consistently, and I’m saying it’s exactly the same this time
.  When I looked, it
popped out of the KOSPI chart down there
[clears throat],
but the flow seems to always be similar.   The
flow since May has been pretty
similar, hasn't it?  The length of the rise is similar, and the
length of the fall is also similar.  So, but what was a little
different this time was that it felt like I
beat them up pretty hard in just one day
.  So,
since the index growth rate has certainly risen compared to the beginning of the year, I think that corrections tend to be
deeper when they occur, and that the rise is
significant when it continues to climb
.  So, I think it is more likely that this time, rather than rebounding sharply from here to go
back to 9,000, it will
fluctuate a bit below before moving up
.   It would have been
nice to get it adjusted like last time when the gap just exceeded 130,
but this time, you pulled it out abruptly before it even reached that point, right
?
And considering the micro-earnings announcements as well, I’ve
recently been thinking that based on past patterns,
the market would rise like this at times like this and then fall, so I’d think, "I should enter right now and sell just before this." But then the market would respond, "Oh, you’re thinking that? I’m going to be one step ahead." Right? The market has
definitely become faster than past patterns
.  Looking at it, if
such quant analysis or similar
strategies were actually used by only a select few,
nowadays, with writers like Kang Han-guk and
myself talking about it,
people with quick wits are changing their approach, thinking, "Okay,
then I should take it down a day earlier
."
Well, wouldn't there be an influence from AI as well?
AI can know anything.   yes
.  If you ask AI, it will teach you everything.   I
told you everything.
So, the thing
itself definitely disappeared.   If the
availability or sheer volume of information was previously limited to
sources or a select few, as mentioned by those who discussed it, it is
now
open to everyone, and the impact of this is indeed due to
AI
.  As Bonus Bat mentioned, as
people become smarter and AI-driven, strategic
battles are becoming more intense. We are
seeing a phenomenon where, if someone says "Oh, three moves, four moves," I can be five moves ahead
.  Anyway, I compared his recent
adjustment to a squall, you know.   Just
as our country is losing its distinct spring and autumn seasons and the weather is getting hotter quickly, bringing frequent downpours, the regular admissions market has similarly
become an incredibly hot market.
Because it is hot, it overheats quickly, and
then the amplitude of such adjustments for ordering the fruit has
definitely changed to the level of the past
.
That is correct.   Please
think of it as a squall.  hmm.
Okay, next, uh, the data from Researcher Lee Yeon-taek has
come out as well.  Let’s
also look at the research materials by Lee Yeon-taek on the final episode of Sollip, "The Order of Leading Stock Collapse According to History."   Since a
lot of time has passed, to
give you a quick overview, well, there was Part 1 and
Part 2, but they say this is the final
year.  Uh, this content is an
excerpt from the industry strategy section regarding the outlook for the second half of 2020. Regarding the detailed information, if you look at the report on the second-half
outlook,
there is a long section written about it.  If you look there, the information is well organized.
This time, as the final installment of the leading stock solution series, I intended to
examine the implications for the current market by looking at the process in which leading stocks collapsed during the late stages of the Dark Combustion
.  It is said that the
full-scale collapse of the NASDAQ first
began in April 2000.  At first, it was
thought that dot-com related stocks would also plummet in unison starting in April, but
looking at the actual data, it is said that there was an order to the decline
.  It is said that the division
began with stocks that brought the distant future closer, and
internet service and wireless communication
companies such as Qualcomm, AOL, and Yahoo were
representative examples.   It is said that
they had
already started to plummet as early as January 2000, even after the NASDAQ recorded its peak
.  It is said that the second
quarter followed in infrastructure-related stocks that reflected excessive CAPEX expectations
. During the dot-com bubble, there was a phenomenon where stock prices skyrocketed based solely on
rumors of launching a dot-com business. A prime
example in Korea is Dialpad, a
free internet phone
service that featured new technology; it reportedly
surged more than 100-fold after its listing based solely on anticipation
.  So, in the current phase, regarding
related stocks, it seems they are talking about the robotics sector and the
research by Lee Yeon-taek.
So, well, it already started dropping a bit early
.  Hyundai cars also
went from almost 800,000 won to 500,000 won
.  They dropped in an instant, and
recently, stocks like LG CNS, which rose after Jensen came along,
as well as Samsung SDS and Naver—which also
surged once after getting somewhat linked to Jensen but immediately came back down—were
mentioned as stocks that [clears throat] dropped first in an instant. And it is said that the
final survivors were companies proven by their earnings.  It is said that as
interest rates
rise and the rally moves into its later stages, the
first targets to watch out for are companies with insufficient profits and whose
break-even point is far in the future
.  It can be said that some
theme stocks related to power, robots, or space in the current market fall into this category
.  On the other hand, it was
stated that the semiconductor sector has the potential to maintain its leading position in the market for a relatively longer period, as it possesses a price-driven investment logic based on an earnings estimate structure and supply shortages.
So, the interesting point is that current investor
sentiment is not much different from that of 30 years ago
.  In fact, when the market was shaken by
issues such as the Samsung Electronics strike in mid-May, the
stock price volatility of robot and space-related theme stocks was
greater than that of electronics. This suggests that investors feel
greater anxiety about theme stocks with insufficient earnings than about semiconductors, which have already risen significantly
.   It was
said that ultimately, even if there is a burden on stock prices, companies proven by performance are likely to survive until the end, and that semiconductors remain the leading candidates in the current market.
[Clears throat]
Uh, quite an interesting reporter. The
collapse of Dacom started in April, but things
like Yau had already started falling out as early as January
.
American Online was like that too, and so on.   It peaked
in December 1999 and fell, and there
was a correction in January as well. However, just like at that time, it was a
period in 2000 when interest rates were continuously being raised.   The reason
interest rates kept rising in 2000 was that, if you
look at things like April 2000, the
experimental rate was even kept consistently low
.  yes.  Since the labor rate
was 3.8 in April, the Fed felt
that employment was solid enough to raise interest rates,
and so they raised it to 6.5. In
the meantime, as I
mentioned last week using the bathhouse analogy,
38°, 39°, 40°, and 41° are
acceptable.  But even at 43 degrees, the
children can't go in.  Kids, right
?  Kids with delicate skin will just jump right out
.  When you reach 44 or 45, things
really heat up, and everyone starts rushing out, but they have
weak stamina,
poor performance, and a plan for the future.  But
right now, the story stocks that require immediate cashing to invest are bound to get
destroyed.
So, even in 2000,
interest rates continued to rise, and while they were moving
from 5.5% to over 6%, the
stocks started to snap like this
.  It was released, and eventually, after the market had already
crashed, they belatedly
began lowering interest rates in December 2000 or 2001. However, stock prices had already
fallen significantly, and companies were
starting to go bankrupt little by little from that time on. As they went
completely wrecked, the
failure rate skyrocketed, exceeding 6%
.   I did tell you that
before, but things are
quite different now compared to back then. Regarding
story stocks here, things like robots and
space are relevant, but what I'm most
worried about is the altcoin
market. When I look at the coin market, a
massive restructuring is currently taking place
.
Then, we will see stocks falling by sector or story, and
as for AI-related stocks currently rising based on earnings—yes, if you think about how long those stocks could
withstand interest rates like this, they can
.
Thank you to the companies that are generating results and already showing numbers.  A lot of time has passed, but
looking through the comments, one
thought comes to mind.
For these athletes, this kind of adjustment
serves as an opportunity to rebalance their sport.
Rebalancing is supposed to be easy, but
when I see people who are dumbfounded, it turns out they are not rebalancing well
.  Actually, there are
many cases where they do the opposite.  Uh, the ones that aren't as bad... I should at least
sell these.
So, I ended up selling the
stocks I should have bought and holding onto the ones I should have sold.
Yes, that is very important.
So, I am currently stuck with a lot of losses.
What should I do about this?  There are many
people like that, but honestly, I thought
selling all those stocks and moving them to our lab was also a good
option
.   Well, if you make a
good judgment, you might see them, but that is the case with
all sports.
When Migi comes, pros overcome it well
.  It is called troubleshooting, but while you can
overcome it and get out,
beginners actually
make their own positioning more difficult.
So, I intended to say that this early period, which looks like a crisis, would be
understandable, but
even though the night futures were down about
1%, our market still
started strong.  yes.   yes
.  It started at 1.8%.
Currently, the rate of increase is expanding to 3.4%
.   yes
.
What happens to KOSDAQ?   yes
.  KOSDAQ is 1.5%.  It started and
began rising.  Currently, it is
falling slightly to 1.1%
.
Fortunately, rebound buying following yesterday's sharp decline is
continuing.
So,
regarding how the US market is expected to turn out, it likely
all declined.  The SP 500 and
Nasdaq went down.
Ah, it dropped.  Oh, that's right.  That's right
.  You said the general market would be positive, so
what was the reason you predicted that Yuripro would drop into negative territory?
Now that you're asking me
suddenly, I don't really remember
.  hmm.
First of all, I think the main reason yesterday was that it was overheated
.  So, I
think I probably [snorted] when I was speaking to you that the Nasdaq would continue to fall even more sharply.   They did
n't say it was fully restored, and it
looks like the adjustments will continue for about another day.   yes
.   So that's what it means
.
What happens today?  [Snoring]
Hmm.
Actually,
[snorting] it is rising a little today as well.   Based
on the gift standard.  However, as you have repeatedly
mentioned, the VIXX index is still at a somewhat high
level, so while we
will know for sure after seeing today's Micro earnings, I
think the index will likely rise.
Actually, since I dropped out in advance,
yes again.
Rather,
all SMP 500 NAS units
will turn positive today.
What happened to Philban?
rising.
Oh, it was a
shower of a day.
yes.  I think it was a full day.
Yes, and it was actually a somewhat good
adjustment.  For those who have none.   It might be
a bit painful for those who are currently working on it,
but I
believe the direction will continue to be one where it surpasses the previous high
.  So I
think I just need to hang in there.  So, I view today
as an upward trend, and I expect the Mycon and
Sushow figures to perform smoothly tomorrow as well.
Since the price has already dropped a bit, I suspect the
pressure regarding earnings might have been somewhat relieved. We will have to see the
tone and numbers tomorrow, but based on
the circumstances, I think the tone will be very strong
.  I think the number will be high as well.
Because, considering the ongoing
expansion of Campex and upward price
adjustments, I
view it positively.
[Clears throat]
Now, next, let's look at the domestic market
.  Domestic market yesterday, KOSPI. Yes.  I was
expecting a bullish candle yesterday, wow
.  But yesterday, I wonder if
my sirang will keep rising from now on
?  I'm a little worried, too.  ruler.   I think so
.
Two semiconductor companies have grown too large in market capitalization
No, but I'm not sure if it's just semiconductors, since everything
else went up sharply as
semiconductors dropped. However, with the semiconductors falling, everything else also showed up in a
beautiful sell-off fashion, so
how do you think it will turn out today? If we look at the Bollinger Bands, well, as I
already mentioned, the Bollinger Bands hit the
upper limit last Friday and came
down.  So, it looks like this week will be a bit
weak.  I
predicted that the market would be strong at the start of the week and likely rebound later on, but since it hit hard early on,
starting today...
however, it rarely goes up in one go, so I
think it might fluctuate a bit at the bottom. But for today, I’ll go with a bullish candle. If it
goes too strong today, even if micro-
earnings come out well tomorrow, I’m thinking of it as a risky move, so I’ll go with a bullish
candle for now
.
How will the KOSDAQ turn out today?  I
said it was a bearish candle, and it was a bearish candle.   Right
?   yes
.  yes.  Another bearish candle today.
It's a bearish candle again today.
Usually, a long bearish candle appears like yesterday
.   yes
.  So, when I used to trade futures,
days like this were relatively easy, but
because the price had dropped significantly, rebound buying would come in at the
beginning.  When
entering for the first time, since we don't do any showcasing, we do
n't make money. However, for things like the
absolute income fund, the unemployment return fund, or
AR ARF, we have to
hatch them. But when a long
candlestick appears like yesterday, the
median of that long candlestick does
n't usually show an engulfing bullish candlestick that strongly breaks through.   hmm.
Scholarship-type beekeeping might happen about once in ten times
?  Statistically speaking, it
fails to recover that median value and drops.
Because yesterday, individual investors bought 11 trillion won
.  People who buy when it drops come back in thinking, "
Oh, I should sell today," and place orders at the
top.
Then, those who dropped without any cash think, "
Oh, I should probably cut back a bit when it comes back up
."  At the same time, having placed it above, and
as I mentioned earlier regarding collections,
if the National Pension Service needs to continue selling, there could be
selling pressure today as well
. As for foreign investors, they are looking at things like interest rates and the Fed's rate hikes. Speaking of short-term foreign investors, their option positions recently are a bit hard to understand, but they have been holding long straddles. Hmm.
But I took a long put and the stock price went up and down, so I was just in a
loss position of 90 to 150 billion won.   hmm.
Ah, [snorting] it was the
first time I’ve seen someone take a long position like this.  That double buying is
actually the opposite concept of a short.   I'm
betting on increased volatility,
so I'm
angry that I'll only make a profit if 7,900 is broken. Yes.  Taking that kind of
position.  And conversely, the same goes for up
.  If it
breaks above 9,500, you will make a profit again
.   hmm.
So, hey, usually it is individual investors who
take long straddles like this, but because the
volatility is high right now, the price of options has
become extremely expensive.  It had gotten expensive, and I
said I would buy it, but yesterday it dropped 10% in one fell swoop
.
So, from the perspective of foreign investors, if it is not yet
falling further,
then foreign investors and option players seem to be
well aware of the semiconductor trading volume and flows coming from Hong Kong-based funds and similar sources. However, in the
case of today, [snorting] what kind of trading have
foreign investors been doing regarding this semiconductor over the past 30 minutes
?
The group is a bit like a cart.  Now,
foreign investors are currently buying about 150 billion won worth of Samsung Electronics shares.  Even
looking at the market as a whole today, foreigners aren't
selling much.  About
580 billion.  There was about a
week's worth of selling at the same time yesterday
.   But it's
already 580 billion.  It is already
selling at around 5,800 won
.
No, of course, the current estimate of foreigners is
based only on foreign channels.  The estimation is
correct.
Then,
Hynix is ​​currently
recorded as having a sell order of approximately -460 billion won.   yes
.  Red.
So today, however, the opening price is about
1%,
or maybe 1.8%. Ah, they say it will come out around 1.8%,
so it might be
a bit difficult for a bullish candlestick pattern to appear right away today.
Yes, I
think it would be good for you to keep that in mind.
Yes, that concludes today's Chaslin Moon Brief
.  In a highly volatile market, yes, the key is to
evaluate the stocks I am investing in; that would be fine
.
yes.  Since I've been trading while chasing market prices without that, I feel
anxious when it drops and happy when it goes up—it feels like that kind of thing
.   I
think it would be good to trade while keeping a bit of a balance regarding that valuation.  yes.
Thank you to everyone for being with us for such a long time.